does this mean that you've managed to
get out of the cave what do you mean
when you say you're living that myth
yeah okay so
i feel like after i wrote american
cosmic you know in the myth do you know
the myth
so my understanding of the cave
myth allegory whatever one wants to call
it is that
there are a set of people and they're
tied up and they're looking at the wall
and on the wall are images which are
adam brations because they're shadows
from something else well we don't know
that they don't know that they mistaken
the wall the cave wall for quote-unquote
reality until one gets loose and then
sees that
these are mere projections of something
else and this outside world is the true
quote-unquote reality
and then people have forgotten about the
third part which is that the sun was too
blinding
and
they have to retreat into the darkness
essentially that there exists such a
thing as too much
truth
and also that they tell people and many
people consider them to be
to cerebrate and insensate much like
right now with people considering those
who
well if you have any belief that is
borderline quote unquote woo
then
that's what one is
labeled yeah so okay so this is that's
generally good good job okay
so there are two things though that i
think that we have to concentrate on
when i finished american cosmic i was
like kind of obsessed with the k the
cave and so i went back and i read
different versions of it you know
translations and everything which then i
realized wait a minute it's not actually
an allegory and wait a minute it's in a
book about politics
and so i thought this is strange and i
also thought this
i thought who are the people that tie us
up
you know because and i asked a lot of my
friends who happen to be philosophers i
said have you ever thought about the
people who tied us up in the cave and
they said oh no no no it's just an
allegory and i was like i don't think so
i think that people actually tied us off
and in fact because of my experience
with american cosmic i believe that
people tied us up
right and so i then have wanted to tell
people
yeah i think that people tied us up i
mean in the cave people tied us up i
know what i'm saying is you believe now
that people tied us up or yeah are you
indicating that the extraterrestrials or
whatever no no no i think that we're
doing it for each other we're you know
we're misinforming each other like
there's obviously this misinformation
campaign that happens for ufos let's
just say that happened we know what
happened yeah so people intentionally
said this is what's happening over here
what you see is real but all of a sudden
we're like whoa what i saw wasn't real
and we and so okay so i became kind of
obsessed with that and trying to get my
friends who are in philosophy to admit
that people tied us up
and then i read it so many times that i
realized that i was that person who was
basically trying to convince people and
that
what happens is you have to basically
just leave the cave
and but there's something at the end of
the that uh the cave allegory i'm just
gonna call an allegory since people have
called it that but it's not um at the
end that person who escapes the cave and
then goes back and tries to tell people
that they're in the cave and then they
don't believe that person and then a
person spends a lot of time
you know precious time basically saying
get out of the cave come on i'll help
you but
they don't and they think you're crazy
and i thought people think i'm crazy and
i said i'm just gonna stop because
that's who i am in this right now in
this in this myth i am that crazy person
he's basically telling people
we got tied up everyone let's get out of
the cave well the the next step
is is what my book is going to be about
the next step is the step
of where that person leaves the cave and
then what they do because they don't
just leave the cave kurt they actually
engage in something and plato calls it a
craft or socrates does plato's the one
who's writing it but socrates calls it a
craft not a not a
flying saucer craft a craft right like a
a way of being
that you engaging with another
and i think that's what i think that's
the heart of it and that's what we
forgot
like we've been kind of hypnotized by
the we are in a cave thing
and we forgot really what he was trying
to tell us and so i'm going to go back
and and kind of
do a reading of that
let me recount it once more so they see
the shadows a guy or girl comes out
notices quote-unquote reality comes back
tries to tell people
and they don't believe him or her then
this person
leaves
to do a craft
what is meant by that
in the book i mean sorry not in your
book necessarily if you don't want to
give it away but in the allegory yeah
allegory yeah so that's the question
what is meant by that so that's i think
the the thing we need to ask
so what happens is that they go out of
the cave
and then he's talking to
i think it's his brother right or his
brother-in-law or something so
in the you know when plato recounts it
socrates is talking to somebody and he
basically says and wouldn't it be the
case
that we engage in this
this dialogue or dialectic
and that this is a craft and that we
this is what we need to do it's almost
like if you want to know the answer for
how to stay out of the cave or the
answer to help you you know
to deal with the reality that we live in
is to engage in this craft and that's
what he's trying to tell us and this
happens to be in a book about
political philosophy
and i think that's really important
and i think that iris murdoch's book
called um
i think it's called the good
um
it's something to do with the good i
just read it
but it's an excellent um it's an
excellent take on this i think she gets
it right
and the take is
that the good is to be political
i know the good is to engage in this
type of um craft that that plato
discusses and it's an answer to the
political
because you know in this talk you and i
have been talking about religion
democracy secularism you know we've been
talking about these different forms of
government and stuff
and plato's basically showing us
something
and then heidegger believe it or not
goes back
and he tries to recreate that through
writing this philosophy where he
questions everything
and so he's basically doing exactly the
craft
although i don't think he actually gets
it as much as iris murdock does
that so that's what's happening and
that's what our that's what our culture
right now we're stuck in the cave and we
just don't we just don't know how to get
out and i think that that's it because
it took me a time it took me a while to
figure it out myself like what is he
saying
and then i had to read it you know how
you can read something so many times and
then finally you're like oh that's what
he's saying right
sometimes it takes a while to because
we've been so
programmed to read it a certain way but
actually i don't think that's the way
it's meant to be read at all the way
that we've been reading it
i was watching a talk of john verveigh's
on heidegger and john was saying in his
language so i'm going to use and this is
a bit esoteric but he was saying that
heidegger was stating that the whole
process of metaphysics for the past 2000
years is one of distancing we distance
ourselves from the
as a subject from the object and
this is perhaps a misframing and that we
shouldn't be seeking propositional
answers but instead participatory
answers so that is
that
it's a difficult
i don't know how to
okay let me think
so a a dance is participatory so there's
a form of knowledge associated with
dancing that's not propositional it's
not writing and then it's not logical
for safe 100 well that's procedural as
well so there's another form so are you
suggesting that
perhaps what's happened is that we've
gotten lost
thinking that the
by elevating the propositional knowledge
and what we need to do is go back to the
participatory yeah and and that's
exactly what i'm saying i am exactly
saying that the way that we've read the
cave right
has been a propositional framework we've
used a propositional framework to read
it
and we've neglected to see the most
important point that is trying to tell
us
and that we have to go back
and look at that and really engage with
what it is that he that he told us back
in the day
and i think that heidegger tried to do
that
i don't i mean he he was successful but
i think that a lot of people just don't
even know understand what heidegger was
doing and i think what you just said was
correct i think we have to be
participatory in that way
engage because the craft isn't engaging
it's a dialectic it's a dialogue
and you do it with a person and you know
what i find fascinating is that you also
see this in buddhism
so what there are these these things
called the three jewels of buddhism one
is the buddha not that you worship this
guy named the buddha it's actually a
title which means awake
and buddhism so you have buddha as the
as an example of what a human being can
become they can become awake
and then you have the dharma which is
the teaching and it doesn't have to be a
book it's anything that's going to wake
you up that's the teaching and then you
have the most important point the sangha
and that's the community
because human beings live together we
don't live as you know so we have to do
this together and i think that that's
what socrates was basically saying is
saying
they're all
in the cave like we you know okay sad
for them you tried to get them out
but now we have each other
and this is what we have to do to keep
each other from being put back in the
cave i mean he was saying that
and he demonstrated it in the book
is there an aspect of meaning associated
with this or rediscovering meaning
yeah
it's a it's a meaning that's intrinsic
now here's the reason i say that it's
because from my understanding of
heidegger and pedigree is one of the
hardest people to read yeah i agree he
makes up his own language
but he was saying look what a lover does
as a if you love your spouse you give
them flowers
you don't give them plants
you don't give
them subjects of
of horticultural investigations
but they're the same
they're actually the same the path in
the flower and the horticultural
investigatory object is the same however
it's wrong to give your spouse
a plant for valentine's day
and so it's because even though the
literal is the same the meaning isn't
and there's something about recapturing
meaning or looking at something in the
correct way that heidegger was pointing
to one of the reasons i like heidegger
is that
in some sense remember i was giving you
an outline of what theories of
everything is
now no way am i saying it's a
continuation of heidegger's project but
it's it's similarly themed in that
he
was suggesting that the
that a project should be that we should
be understanding
our being in order to understand our
relationship to being in order to
understand being and while what is being
well being is
i i don't know how to describe what
heidegger would say being is other than
existence and earlier you mentioned that
heidegger was interested in why
something exists i think that
wittgenstein was interested in why
something exists and how something
exists where heidegger was interested in
existence what is existence itself i
agree with you i think so i think also
that wittgenstein realized that language
actually couldn't
contain
a lot of what existence is about and
then you know he kind of gave up on it
he said
i think his famous quote is of that
which we cannot speak we should remain
silent which i of course don't agree
with because then you have art right and
music so let's not remain silent that
would take away a good part of what
living is about so
yeah
well he also was an artist he i don't
know if he meant language per se rather
than art maybe art wasn't it was a
was all right to
as a mode of expressing oneself to
understand the world it's strange
because i was looking up heidegger and
heidegger apparently was an atheist but
i see him as in a sense wrestling with
god or trying to figure out what god is
and same with wittgenstein
wittgenstein i don't think he explicitly
called himself an atheist but either way
norman malcolm i don't know if you know
this his friend norman malcolm said the
religiosity that characterized
wittgenstein was greater than the
average religious person and
wittgenstein he said he can't help but
see every problem through religious
point of view so i see heidegger
similarly or even though he may say he's
an atheist it seems like what he's doing
is is trying to understand god
well i mean there's a reason why i'm
very attracted to his work and
you know and i i find it to be mystical
i think that his later work was he he
had a mystical experience and they tried
to
express that that understanding through
his and i think that's why he went
pre-socratic he went back to you know
socrates and
pre-socratics in order to
you know to express what he thought we
had lost as a culture
have you heard from many of the people
who are on the more buddhist slash
eastern end that would say that you
cannot discover god or
reality or whatever
synonym one wants to give it that has
some dramatic flair to it
you cannot discover it via an analytical
approach that you must experience it has
to be something that is beyond language
do you
have firstly have you heard that and
then secondly if you have do you believe
that to be the case
yes so i would say that um beyond
heidegger's writing and on a hannah
aren't writing
i was very influenced by the writings of
the people involved in what's called the
kyoto school
so the kyoto school was a japanese
school of zen buddhism philosophers they
didn't call themselves religious
religion wasn't even a term for them but
they they were using zen in order to
explicate like philosophy and that's how
heidegger kind of got involved with them
and um one of my
one of the books that i think is most
fascinating i think it's called um
i think it's called the philosophy of
nothingness and i forgot exactly who
wrote it but it's that person his he has
that's where he links he actually went
back and read nietzsche and kind of
through the lens of zen buddhism and i
thought it was a fascinating book um so
if you're interested it's the philosophy
of nothingness
so yes absolutely that's what he's
basically saying i mean i also think
that nietzsche was a mystic as well you
know his his his flashes is basically
mysticism now nietzsche is someone that
i feel horrible for not liking because
everyone likes yeah
but i don't i i just can't i'd rather
read what other people have said about
him than he then go to the primary
source which is anathema to
to scholars because it's well to me the
way that i view it it's like wine you
you
i for me when i drank which i don't
drink anymore but i was never partial to
wine to wine i i
i'll have some of it but then the same
with the stronger drinks they don't
taste good but i'm not going to torture
myself
by constantly drinking it in order to
get the quote-unquote in acquired taste
so i think that's what's necessary in
order to understand nietzsche properly
no it's not did did you not read about
my nietzsche synchronicity that caused
because i hated it yeah yeah well well
good for you in the sense that you're
lucky that you have that no i know
because i would have continued to hate
nietzsche as well just like you and good
for you i i would be very suspicious of
a person who naturally liked nietzsche
frankly i think you have to encounter
nietzsche
so yeah i mean a lot of what he says is
horrible
[Laughter]
so i'm much more of a lovecraftian in
the sense that you mentioned the cave
allegory and i'm much more inclined to
feel like that
and i used to be of the type that give
me the truth and no matter what form it
comes but i've had some experiences
where
i feel like sometimes the truth is far
too much for you to handle and you can
you can damage yourself
drastically from
an encounter with the truth and
lovecraft had this
this quote which which to me i interpret
as the case for ignorance and it's it's
something like the greatest mercy in the
world is the inability for the human
mind to correlate its contents
and that
one day we'll see that this
unfettered scientific investigation may
bring about such a terrifying vista of
reality that we'll see
our fragile place in it and be so
frightened that we'll either go mad from
the revelation or
or flee from the light into the peace
and security of the dark ages
so
in the cave allegory i see that as the
person who runs back in the cave
now you mentioned that there may be a
solution to that and i well i'm i'm
praying and i'm hoping that your book
provides some solution to that because
right now i'm fleeing from the
from the
from the light let's say
you mean you're going back into the cave
i i it's yes i i wish and i i hope when
i pray for the for the cave i think that
the
the more fiendish and cursed aspects of
a quote-unquote open mind haven't been
explicated by people or even recognized
that it's seen in this culture is
something that one everyone should have
more of and i think that my mind has
been somewhat
too open and i need to close it and it's
not pleasant to have such an open mind
no i'm not saying that as something yet
yeah that's where the sangha comes in
that's where you have to have people
that help you
because it's not it's not easy to have
an open mind especially when everyone
around us is you know like they are and
that's why
i mean that's why it's necessary it's
not just
something helpful it's necessary
well well
i
i'm very much looking forward to reading
that book do you have a title
right now i'm calling it the resurrected
because it's it's you know it's people
that have gone through
death in a sense
and are now alive again
and so i thought that's
they're resurrected
yeah
have you gone through
well what's the difference between
epistemic shock and ontological shock
okay so i think that epistemic shock is
when you realize that the world you
thought you knew and the assumptions
that you had about it were wrong and
that
instigates probably ontological shock
where
it's ontological in the sense that
you can no longer live the same
like you know the ways in which you live
now have to change
so i see them as happening at
one right after the other
one is kind of theoretical and the other
is
institutional luck
well okay to to make a play on words
there i feel like i have gone through
somewhat of each of those shocks and
have almost been to the point where i
need to be institutionalized and so it's
it's actually extremely frightening to
study consciousness and what reality is
and to constantly have
one's
world view
shattered
and
and and some and even do so for a living
which is what this channel is it's it's
not a
it's not pleasant
and
well it's not pleasant luckily i'm like
just getting out of it it's only
by the grace of god
just getting out of it but
it's not pleasant
i'm i'm wondering what was your
epistemic and ontological shock
specifically was there a moment
yes um it happened in i think it was
2012
and it was during the whole weekend
and it was just after the you know that
i think it was in march that the tsunami
happened in 2011
and that was shocking of course
but after that i had a very
very real sense of impending
you know this could happen and it's
terrible like a whole civilization could
like get washed out or you know
something could happen and
apocalyptic kind of feelings and that's
when i was doing the research that i was
doing into the ufo
realities
and that's when i i went back and i
looked at some of the primary source
material for catholic history and i
realized what was happening
was happening now
and that people and that and that's when
i met people who
seemed to care
that i knew and that's those were like
you know the people we referred to
earlier
and i guess the reality of this shocked
me on a level that that i call it
pre-ufo diana and post-ufo diana right
okay and it definitely wasn't pleasant
so it was um and it lasted it was for
the weekend it was so
destabilizing
great work
yeah so i was destabilized so
but
i had a lot to fall back on
because i'd study religion my whole life
so i knew from buddhism and from
catholicism that there were
you know there are ways to get through
this because i read it you know it's
called uh saint john of the cross calls
it the dark knight of the soul okay oh
you know you to oh sorry sorry just as a
quick side i was being interviewed by
someone telling them about my experience
and they said kurt it sounds like you're
going through the dark knight of the
soul
yeah that's what you that's what it is
it's the dark night of the soul so okay
so think about it now i've had i've read
all of this and knew all of these things
so i already had something to fall back
on which is why you don't
but you know nietzsche comes in handy
here because nietzsche went through it
too i it almost seems like he didn't
survive it frankly because he was so he
didn't have a sangha it didn't seem like
and he didn't have
you know he didn't have the well
heidegger had the catholic tradition
which he was able to
you know he also had his friends at the
kyoto school
you know
try going through satori experiences and
and stay stable right so you know so he
had like a lot of people so i think that
that's something that we have to take
into consideration here is that i think
you know stay away from
like
gather around yourself some people who
have been through it so that they can
say
oh yeah
been there you know what i mean so like
i get it you know
so you need a sangha so um
so that's what i had i had um i had i
have a woman named sister rose
so she's a catholic uh ursuline sister
and
this is how she put it she said
diana she said
this is what's going on she said you've
and jeff kreipel has a book called
flipped
in which he talks exactly about this
he says you flip jeff [ __ ] yeah he's
at rice university you should have him
on your show he's great
so he's a professor at rice university
and basically he went through the same
he was a he was in training to be a monk
and then
he recognized that he couldn't be so he
became a professor of religion
and he had it he had some cool
experiences okay so um
but he knows what this is about and so
does cisco rose sister rose said
we tend to think that the world is like
how we were brought up to believe and
then all of a sudden we have experiences
that show us that the world is actually
not like that at all and then we
sometimes we never get over that she
says but
we're here like you know her order you
know and her and the catholic you know
the the people of the church you know
they had mystical experiences she said
this tradition is here to tell you that
we are in the world but we are not of
the world and that actually makes sense
now to me because i was like
ah that's what that means she said it's
really like the way you see it now
that's really how the world
looks but it's not like how these other
people see it she said they just think
that it's like that but they're not
actually you know it might happen to
them too at some point they might get
flipped she goes but mostly probably
won't because it doesn't happen to
everyone it only happens to a few
so does that make sense so there are
people to which this has happened
and now they live in this reality and
that reality for them
is um
is the normal reality
what do you mean when you say it is the
world is actually how it looks
well when i say okay so you know when
you you've gone through a night of the
soul of the dark night of the soul and
the next day or you know when for me it
was that weekend
and then i was i said to myself okay
i have a new perspective on what life is
about
and
now i'm going to have to live with this
new perspective i don't know what it's
going to be like
and so that's what she was trying to
explain to me she was trying to explain
that
you you don't have to go back to the
perspectives and use those as tools for
interpreting the world she said
you're fresh it's like you're born again
you're new in this new world and now you
have to use different tools but
thankfully because i've been studying
about religion and philosophy my whole
life i had all those tools
but i just didn't know that that's what
i was doing my whole life i was
preparing myself to kind of do that by
use by learning those tools and now like
i have a lot of people who come to me
who are students or
you know who are grown-ups you know and
this has happened to them and they're
like what do i do and then i give them
you know say okay this is you know a lot
of times in their own tradition they'll
have a book that they just
they read but they forgot about
and then they'll go back and they'll say
oh
so people have gone through this
and this sangha i imagine that's a
community where people have similar
values what is it yeah so in the
buddhism um it's the sangha is the
community of people who are waking up
and helping each other stay awake
because buddhism is about waking up from
the illusion
yeah
so they're waking up so yeah exactly
that's where i am i want i i used to
envy people i don't i don't want to be
awake any longer and and you know
there's great research that says sleep
is helpful sleep is healthy sleep is
we're not sleeping enough i would like
to go back to sleep personally
i hear what you're saying yeah i
understand
but the sangha is there for you
when you go through the process of
awakening
they're there to help you out
and those are those are those are the
three things that you need in buddhism
okay so that's what i'm saying is like
buddhism
to me looks very similar to
the thing that socrates suggests we do
at the end of the cave
it's this is an engaging kind of thing
like what you said participatory
so it involves other people you can't do
it alone
i also find that for so that you
mentioned the song is awakened people
but i find that the more i interact with
people in general the more i go out the
more it's not just my wife because i
pretty much only interact with her
because
well for the past couple of years
because of covid and the more that i see
family and
and talk to people at coffee shops and
so on and i'm friendly
the the more it well that drastically
helps me but they're not people who i
would
consider to be awakened per se i just
say they're people
so is is am i not doing it correctly
no no i mean i think you're doing it
correctly because i think in buddhism
too anything can be a teaching like
dharma is the teaching whatever kind of
helps you it could be circumstances it
could be events it doesn't have to be a
book it doesn't have to be a song or a
movie or a person talking to you i think
that being around people though i mean
we have been through a lot through kovid
and i think just getting out and talking
to people we're naturally
we're beings who who like to be around
people and then like to have our space
right so i think that's natural it's
kind of like
eating we need to eat so we definitely
need to be around people and i think
that covid is has maybe caused a lot of
us to
be in the cave too long or something
literally an introvert you would
consider yourself to be an introvert
definitely i'm an introvert yeah
but um but i'm a good i'm an introvert
that's learned how to be an extrovert
because of my job same same yeah yeah
yeah okay i'm gonna tell you this and
but i'm not gonna i'm gonna take this
off the record so what happened to me
was i i had it it's at this point that i
suggest you watch the carl fristen
episode i consider that to be the most
important of all the theories of
everything
videos mainly because it serves as a
cautionary tale
like mentioned in the beginning and also
because i don't like talking about this
experience and this may be the last time
that i do so so if you would like more
context then visit that link in the
description thank you
and if you've experienced something
similar just know that you're not alone
and that the more that people talk about
this sort of issue the less humiliation
and disrepute will be thrown around
because many many many more people have
experiences like this than you think
it's just that most people don't talk
about it at all because they're afraid
and being i
understand what it's like to be afraid
trust me
either way you are not alone
luckily i haven't had like i'm saying
luckily because i don't want any more
experiences like that that shattered me
i don't have the strength to go through
that or i think i don't have the
strength but anyway and then hanging
around people and someone's helping me
so that's an aside like jess you will
take all of that out but i just wanted
you to know that that's the context from
where i'm coming from i encourage that
you hang out with them those people
because what i found in my life too was
that a lot of the people that seem to
understand how being
like really being
human and good were people that weren't
philosophers you know they were people
who were i was involved in a homeschool
group with my kids and these were just
catholics who believed pretty straight
up
not complicated catholicism right so i
wouldn't and never talk to them about
the stuff i'm talking to you about and
um
that was as that was good for me and
that was good for my kids so um i think
i go to church
and a lot of my friends who are
intellectuals think i'm crazy
but i go
and i think that these things these
simple things
i think they're good mm-hmm
that's the aspect of religion that
that it's
it's not valued enough in the
irreligious circles so they'll say yeah
well like if they're going to ascribe
any salutary components of religion they
would say well it promotes community
yeah that's a huge huge huge yes you
have no clue
yeah and that's why i say the sangha
it's one of the three things it's called
the three jewels of buddhism they
definitely understand it
it's community
and did you know that in catholicism
it's actually considered a sacrament
community
what's a sacrament meaning oh a
sacrament means it's a um it's imbued
with the power of god
so community like a church community is
imbued with the power of god